one of the candidates who is not on the
stage tonight is Tom Styer billionaire
businessman and activist who has spent
millions of his own money fighting for
several Democrat causes before jumping
in this race he joins us tonight live
from New Hampshire mr. Starr thanks for
being here
Bret thank you very much for having me I
want to go through a couple process
things and then get to some of the
issues that you I know want to talk
about you I assume are the primary
concern for you is to get president
Trump out of office you've spent a lot
of your own money to try to do just that
but when you looked at the field of
20-plus Democratic candidates what did
you say did you say that they can't win
so I need to get in to do it my real
motivation here Brett is that I was
worried that we wouldn't deal with the
basic problems in front of Americans and
wouldn't be telling the truth about what
we needed to do the number one issue for
Americans that I have been calling out
is that we've had a failure of the
federal government we've had a corporate
takeover of our federal government that
we've that they've actually bought the
government and that we need to restore
our democracy to get back to government
of By and For the People that puts the
interests of the American people first
not the profits of corporations but
obviously that's what I'm doing for your
field and decided I'm better than the 20
plus candidates standing there well I
was worried Bret that we would be
talking about plans we would be talking
about plans in terms of medical care
healthcare we'd be talking about plans
in terms of education we'd be talking
about the plans that you were just
referencing with regards to the green
New Deal
but that what we needed to level with
the American people about was for any of
those plans to be seriously considered
we'd have to break this corporate
stranglehold on our democracy I think
four out of five Americans Republicans
Democrats and independents think that
this democracy has been bought by
corporations it goes and cross-party
issues it goes apart across geography
and that's what I think we have to
confront can we get back a federal
government that works can we restore
government of By and For the People
I mean you know that
critics in your own party including
Bernie Sanders have said they don't like
that billionaires are in this race
trying to buy this race and those were
in their words I want to just ask you
about where you're standing you're not
on the next debate in Houston you're not
invited to the Town Hall tonight on
climate change a key topic for you the
Real Clear Politics average of polls of
recent polls has you at point four
percent for someone looking in the
Democratic primary or caucuses at you
why should they believe that you're
gonna make it well I've been in this
race for six or seven weeks Brett and
I've been spending my time in the early
primary States that's New Hampshire Iowa
South Carolina and Nevada and if you
look in those states I'm somewhere
between six and seven percent and I'm
either in fourth place or in fifth place
so my point to you is my message that we
need to break this corporate
stranglehold and that I'm someone who's
been doing that as an outsider in
politics for 10 years putting together
coalition's of normal ordinary American
citizens to break the corporate
stranglehold and winning is something
that actually is resonating in the
places where my message is going out
that people do hear it and they are
responding positively and I expect
they'll continue to let's talk about
some substance tonight they're doing
these climate change town halls it is a
big issue for you one of the things
you've talked about is getting back into
the Paris Accord is that right
well actually Brett of course I would
get back into the Paris Accord but I
view that as a important symbolic
gesture but not actually something
that's gonna change what the world does
or what America does what I've said much
beyond getting back into the Paris
Accord is that I would declare a state
of emergency on day one and I would use
the emergency powers of the presidency
to start us to deal with the issue of
climate change to make it priority one
and to make sure that we protect the
health and safety of every American at
on day one as commander-in-chief yeah
you I mean you criticize the president
for pulling
out of the Paris Accord and there are
other Democrats who have done the same
thing what do you say to people who said
that that was just a not a good deal to
begin with one of them is our former
colleague here at Charles Krauthammer
who I had on the panel when all that was
happening tickle is right now it makes
no sense it has no enforcement mechanism
it's all voluntary people are supposed
to adhere to certain limits self-imposed
that's the problem with it
the Chinese essentially have a free ride
for 15 years
the Indians have announced that they're
going to increase co2 emissions they're
going to triple them from coal between
now and 2030 we're the ones you're gonna
have to adhere to these limits and after
that President Trump pointed out that
the US is actually reducing emissions
more than any other country well let me
say this the Paris Accord is by no means
perfect but if we're going to push the
inter this is a global problem bred and
you know it we all know it's a global
problem if we're gonna solve it we're
gonna have to solve it on a global basis
that means two things
it means America has to go back to being
the moral leader of the world moral
technological commercial leader of the
world which is what we've been for more
than a century and secondly it means for
us to do that for us to go to India and
go to China and say this is what we're
gonna have to do together we're gonna
have to have our house in order and I
can tell you this as a businessman I've
studied this for over a decade and we
can do this in a way that will have
lower cost of energy will grow faster as
a country people will have higher wages
and will be healthier this whole
argument that this is going to be
somehow a drag on the American economy
is completely false in truth this is
something that can restore us as a
country and make us richer and make us
healthier last thing one of the other
things that you're pushing for and I've
spent a lot of money on is an
impeachment effort the latest Monmouth
poll out says should a president Trump
be impeached or compelled to leave
presidency and you see the no has
increased actually since May March May
and then August 59 35 upside down do you
still believe that this president should
be impeached you know Brett I really do
I think he's the most corrupt president
in American history I think he's more
than met the criteria for impeachment
and I think he threatens the safety of
Americans but more than that he
threatens the whole idea for the rule of
law the president can't be above the law
if we're to be a nation of laws so do I
believe that we should stand up on
behalf of the American people to protect
our Constitution and our way of life of
course I do
that's never changed that I always felt
that what we were standing for was the
right of every American citizens to be
judged fairly for nobody to be a king
and for nobody to be above the law but
for us to be citizens together
Tom Styer in New Hampshire tonight on
the campaign trail mr. Stahr we
appreciate your time